just before the new year british
socialite and jeffrey epstein paramore
galen maxwell was convicted of sex
trafficking of a minor transporting a
minor with the intent to engage in
criminal sexual activity conspiracy to
entice a minor to travel for the purpose
of engaging in illegal sex acts and
conspiracy to transport a minor with the
intent to engage in criminal sexual
activity the maxwell trial was a bonanza
for conspiracy theorists because the
characters include some of the most
famous people in the world a victim said
that she was recruited by epstein when
she worked as a 15 year old at donald
trump's florida resort mar-a-lago one of
the prosecutors was maureen comey
daughter of james comey super lawyer
alan dershowitz helped epstein to get a
plea deal for abusing young girls and
then was accused of participating in the
sexual abuse of two girls in epstein's
orbit friend of jeffrey prince andrew
parted with epstein at mar-a-lago and is
in the midst of a legal battle with a
woman who says andrew and epstein abused
her bill clinton admitted to flying with
jeffrey epstein four times donald trump
that he fell out with epstein but
complimented maxwell saying i wish her
well i just wish her well frankly and of
course epstein and maxwell are known to
be in the orbit of many famous democrats
and republicans and then of course
there's epstein himself who killed
himself in prison before he could be
tried in court launching speculation
that he was murdered at the behest of
the clintons or by then president trump
or by the cia or some other shadowy
cabal but all of these famous names and
outlandish theories tend to diminish
what the victims say actually happened
to them that they were sexually abused
by epstein and aided and abetted by
maxwell when they were minors so in this
video we'll explain what really happened
in the maxwell trial what did the victim
say about epstein and maxwell how many
years could she face in prison and what
happens next and most importantly why
could one juror undo the entire trial
[Music]
so let's start at the beginning who is
galain maxwell maxwell is a french-born
oxford educated socialite she is the
daughter of robert maxwell who escaped
nazi persecution in what was then
czechoslovakia on the eve of world war
ii robert emigrated to france and then
to great britain where he eventually
became a member of parliament for six
years gillane is the youngest of nine
children in 1991 her father drowned on a
yacht named the lady galain after his
beloved daughter by the end of his life
robert was a media tycoon who owned
several newspapers and publishing
companies after his death the world
learned that robert had been laundering
pension funds and embezzling money but
despite the scandal glenn maxwell's
family connections enabled her to form
relationships with rich and famous
people from around the world which she
leveraged when she met epstein in the
early 1990s epstein was an incredibly
wealthy man though it seems that nobody
knows precisely how he made his money or
how much he made epstein was briefly a
professor hired by the father of former
attorney general william barr later he
became a traitor for bear stearns where
he was made partner in just four years
after leaving stearns epstein went into
business for himself most of epstein's
acquaintances have said that epstein was
a money manager who only accepted
clients who had one billion dollars or
more epstein eventually purchased a
private island and had two jets which he
used to entertain friends he also became
a philanthropist allegedly giving away
hundreds of millions of dollars to
charitable causes but in reality it
seems that the epstein foundation turned
out to be a mirage to gain tax
exemptions and rehabilitate his image
after his 2005 florida sex abuse case in
2005 the police investigated the
financier for abusing underage girls one
of the accusers told the miami herald
that he was preying on 14 year old girls
who were quote basically homeless at the
time epstein called on alan dershowitz
to attack the accuser's character and
negotiated a non-prosecution agreement
that allowed epstein to plead guilty to
one count of solicitation with no
additional charges he served 13 months
in a county jail on work release as long
time legal eagles know the prosecutor
who negotiated the deal was alex acosta
who later became the secretary of labor
for donald trump and acosta resigned
after criticism of the deal you can
watch my video about epstein and acosta
for more information it is
to put it mildly bonkers now some have
suggested that epstein also made money
by blackmailing his rich and famous
friends when the fbi raided his
properties they found hundreds and
perhaps thousands of sexually suggested
photographs of nude females the fbi also
seized compact discs that were labeled
with the words young blank name plus
name virginia robert dufrey publicly
accused epstein and britain's prince
andrew of sexual abuse she says american
law enforcement have video footage of
her having sex with members of epstein's
elite friend group now all this
indicates that authorities have
significant information about epstein's
activities and they know that he broke
the law but in 2019 epstein committed
suicide in jail but despite years of
accusations that maxwell participated in
the abuse she managed to stay on the lam
for years until she was arrested at home
in new hampshire in 2021. federal
prosecutor allison moe called her quote
a sophisticated predator and the key to
epstein's criminal abuse of girls which
takes us to the trial of gelane maxwell
maxwell stood trial on six charges of
committing sex crimes against minors the
crimes happened between 1994 and 2004
and we do know that epstein had a
history of abusing underage girls often
during encounters that started with a
girl giving epstein a massage epstein
promised girls to help with their
personal problems pledged to fund their
educations made them believe that he
would help them launch their careers in
music massage or any area where the girl
expressed interest the epstein
encounters happened at his properties
all over the world four victims
testified during this trial helping
prosecutors to show a pattern of abuse
so what was maxwell's alleged role in
this well federal prosecutor said that
she actively groomed underage girls and
then brought them into epstein's
household the victims testified that
maxwell facilitated the abuse of
underage girls she gained their trust by
taking them shopping inviting them to
luxurious estates and on expensive trips
all the while making it seem like they
were safe but then she basically acted
like a madam and an accomplice luring
the girls into sexual encounters with
epstein and maxwell herself the
prosecution showed that during this time
frame epstein transferred over 30
million dollars to maxwell so how did
epstein and maxwell coerce girls into
traveling with them well witnesses said
that they pretended that they were
mentoring the girls one witness
testified that epstein paid for her to
attend a performing arts camp another
witness said that epstein funded her
travels under the guise of helping her
improve her college prospects
prosecutors told the jury that the
evidence would prove that all of these
activities were just subtext for
grooming the girls for sexual abuse the
prosecution's expert witness lisa rakio
who was a therapist claimed that the
predator's selective vulnerable victims
isolate them from friends and family
earn their trust with money and gifts
and then begin the abuse one of the
victims said that she was in a
vulnerable position when she met epstein
her father had died and epstein promised
to fund her college education the woman
who testified said that maxwell first
presented herself as a wise older sister
but then started casually mentioning how
they should touch epstein during a
massage their accounts of the abuse were
supported by people who worked for
epstein juan alessa a former housekeeper
in palm beach said he was asked to drive
maxwell around to the massage parlors
and spas in the local area looking for
girls that they could recruit
david rogers flew epstein for over 30
years he kept a meticulous personal
flight log of the more than 1 000 times
he flew one of epstein's private planes
a redacted version of the flight logs
was entered into evidence and these
heavily redacted flight logs were pretty
damning the logs showed that epstein and
other passengers flew with some of the
victims from 1996 to 1998 confirming one
of the victim's stories the flight logs
also confirmed that epstein's accuser
virginia jeffrey had indeed flown on the
airplane with epstein juffrey has
accused prince andrew of sexually
abusing her when she was 17 years old
prince andrew for his part admits
hanging out with epstein but denies the
allegations lawrence vizoski one of
epstein's pilots said he never witnessed
sexual activity on the planes however he
also said that the cockpit door was
always kept closed during flights on the
plane nicknamed the lolita express now
the most serious charge against maxwell
was for sex trafficking a minor the
indictment said that maxwell quote
assisted facilitated and contributed to
jeffrey epstein's abuse of minor girls
by among other things helping epstein to
recruit groom and ultimately abuse
victims known to maxwell and epstein to
be under the age of 18. now sex
trafficking is covered by 18 usc 1591
and it applies to anyone who knowingly
recruits entices harbors transports
provides or obtains by any means a
person knowing that the person has not
attained the age of 18 years and will be
caused to engage in a commercial sex act
now this charge relates solely to
maxwell's actions towards victim carolyn
who was abused by epstein when she was
in her teens carolyn who withheld her
last name told the jury that when she
was 14 she was sexually abused by
maxwell and epstein she testified about
setting up a massage room for epstein
when maxwell came into the room and
touched carolyn's body caroline
estimates that she visited epstein's
florida house over 100 times between
2001 and 2004 and each time she visited
300 in cash was left for her on the
bathroom sink for sex trafficking minor
maxwell faces up to 40 years of
imprisonment as a first-time offender
the jury also found maxwell guilty of
enticing a minor to travel and
transporting a minor across state lines
federal criminal law prohibits a wide
range of activities relating to
transporting people and traveling across
state lines or internationally for the
purpose of engaging in legal sexual
conduct uh 18 usc 2422 prohibits anyone
from knowingly persuading inducing
enticing or coercing an individual to
travel interstate or foreign commerce
with the purpose of engaging in
prostitution or any criminal activity or
attempting to do so victim jane who
testified under an assumed name said
that when she was 14 years old maxwell
and epstein approached her at an arts
camp in michigan this was the beginning
of several years of abuse which happened
at epstein's palm beach mansion
jane testified that she was forced to
give epstein a massage that he'd turned
sexual and she testified that maxwell
was often in the room during that abuse
jane said that maxwell gained her trust
and made her feel like she was an older
sister which paved the way for the abuse
the abuse occurred when jane was 14 15
and 16 years old now the jury acquitted
maxwell of an enticing charge but
convicted her for transporting jane when
she was a minor and since jane was then
under 18 the penalty is up to 15 years
in jail now maxwell was found guilty of
three charges of conspiracy related to
the charges that we just talked about
conspiracy to commit sex trafficking of
a minor conspiracy to entice a minor to
travel to engage in criminal sexual
activity and conspiracy to transport a
minor with the intent to engage in
criminal sexual activity prosecutors
charge maxwell with conspiracy charges
for agreeing to do these crimes which
was paired with the substantive charges
for committing those specific crimes now
to convict someone of conspiracy the
prosecutor simply has to prove that the
defendant committed overt acts in
furtherance of the conspiracy and
remember a conspiracy charge is sort of
an empty vessel it requires a predicate
illegal conduct for which multiple
people are agreeing or helping out with
and here the prosecution laid out a
criminal conspiracy between maxwell and
epstein to abuse minor girls often by
transporting them to epstein's house in
new york florida new mexico and england
maxwell encouraged underage girls to
participate in these massages with
epstein while they were in england all
the while knowing that the girls would
be sexually abused during the massages
maxwell was also charged with enticing a
female victim to travel from florida to
new york in order to facilitate sex acts
with epstein now maxwell's defense was
that she was just an innocent bystander
who did not participate in the abuse of
the victims maxwell argued that the
victims had been manipulated by their
lawyers and she also argued that epstein
manipulated maxwell using the same
tactics that he used on the girls and
the defense attorneys challenged the
memories of the four victims who
testified there were some discrepancies
in the victim's recollections about what
happened but generally speaking they'd
seem to be pretty minor details and the
jury clearly believed that while the
victims might have gotten some of the
more minor details wrong
dealing with events that took place
almost 20 years ago that they believed
the more important facts that epstein
abused underage girls and that maxwell
facilitated that abuse that's not
surprising given the pilot logs
establishing that the girls traveled
with epstein and maxwell coupled with
their testimony about how maxwell
groomed them which damaged maxwell's
defense and i guess the jury didn't
believe that maxwell was an innocent
bystander now the maximum penalty on all
five counts for maxwell is 65 years but
the guidelines usually recommend lower
sentences for first-time offenders and
the maximum penalty rarely tells you
anything about the
sentence that a defendant will actually
serve federal sentences are almost
always adjusted depending on whether
there was aggravating factors or
mitigating factors and these adjustments
are found in the federal sentencing
guidelines and it's likely maxwell won't
face anything like 65 years in jail
though she will definitely be in jail
for quite a long time now when weighing
maxwell's sentence the judge will have
to consider the size and scope of the
criminal activity and the person's role
in it in the maxwell's case epstein's
two pilots
described her as his number two
epstein's former house manager told the
jury that maxwell described herself as
the lady of the house though if the
judge finds that she was a manager or
supervisor but not an organizer or
leader then her exposure would increase
by only three levels and if she was an
organizer leader manager or supervisor
in any criminal activity her guideline
score only goes up by two levels
calculating actual sentences can be a
very fact intensive endeavor and it can
be kind of tricky but federal
prosecutors
predict that maxwell's involvement was
significant enough to warrant a 20 to 25
year sentence now some people have
suggested that maxwell may look to
cooperate with prosecutors to reduce her
sentence but since epstein is dead and
prosecutors regard her as his second in
command it's not clear what she really
has to gain or what prosecutors would
want with her and that's not the end of
the road for maxwell's woes later this
year she will stand trial on charges
that she lied under oath about epstein's
abuse of underage girls and according to
prosecutors maxwell perjured herself
during a 2016 deposition in the virginia
jufrey case where she told lawyers under
oath that she did not know about
epstein's abuse of the girls and did not
know about recruitment and interactions
with underage girls though on the other
hand one of the quirks of conspiracy
charges is that the statute of
limitations doesn't run until the last
overt act in the conspiracy has been
committed so even though we're talking
about events that took place in the 90s
and early 2000s the conspiracy still
continued decades after the initial
predicate acts which means that
the other people who engaged in these
acts and engaged in this conspiracy can
still be found guilty of the conspiracy
charges even though the underlying
statute of limitations might have
already run and it's clear that here in
the maxwell trial maxwell was engaging
in all kinds of overt acts in
furtherance of the conspiracy including
trying to cover it up years after the
initial acts took place so it's possible
that other people who might have engaged
in some of these actions and engaged in
these uh overt acts and further into the
conspiracy might still be able to be
brought to justice even though it were
decades after the initial acts but
that's not the end of this story just
one week after the guilty verdict two
jurors spoke out to the media about
their own histories of sexual abuse now
why would that be a problem well the
jurors reveal that they shared their
experiences as sexual abuse during jury
deliberations and one of the jurors or
both of them may have failed to disclose
their history in a jury questionnaire
their revelations could result in a new
trial for maxwell the first juror
scottie david identified only by his
first and middle names
told two reporters that he talked about
his experiences as a victim to assuage
doubts that other jurors had about the
testimonies of the alleged victims
i can't remember all the details there
are some things that run together when i
shared that they were able to sort of
come around on they were able to come
around on the memory aspect of the
sexual abuse he had allegedly answered
no to the question of whether he'd ever
been a victim of such a crime and the
second juror told the new york times
that they also shared a personal
experience of sexual abuse that appeared
to help shape the jury's discussions now
as you probably know during the jury
selection process which is called voidir
lawyers have the opportunity to screen
jurors for who will hear the case
lawyers can strike a limited number of
potential jurors for no cause whatsoever
which means for any reason as long as
the reason isn't a person's race or
gender these are known as preemptory
challenges but lawyers or the judge can
also challenge jurors for cause
potential jurors are excused for cause
when the judge finds that they cannot
decide the case impartially now a
person's experiences and opinions don't
automatically mean that they are unable
to perform the duties of a juror the
same is true when someone has a strong
partisan opinion a gun reform advocate
would not automatically be disqualified
to sit on the written house jury nor
would a gun rights advocate a person who
has been sexually abused is not
necessarily disqualified to sit on a
jury involving sexual assault the key
question is whether a person can set
aside their opinions and experiences to
decide questions fairly and impartially
so how do judges and lawyers figure out
if someone can be impartial well during
voir dire lawyers ask probing questions
to prospective jurors and the judge does
as well jurors are required to be
truthful in this process and as long as
a prospective juror discloses relevant
facts a judge will usually take their
word for it if they say that they can
set aside their own feelings in order to
render a fair judgment now you may
wonder whether people have ever lied to
get on a jury and although this has
certainly happened it's also common for
a juror upon examination by the judge to
admit that they would have trouble
putting aside their personal biases to
render a fair verdict which effectively
excuses themselves from the jury and
really that's what lawyers want
conflicted jurors to do they really
don't want a situation where a juror
lies about their ability to render a
fair verdict so what's the standard for
a fair trial because a juror lied in the
voideer process well the supreme court
outlined that standard in 1984.
we hold that to obtain a new trial in
such a situation a party must first
demonstrate that a juror failed to
answer honestly a material question on
voideer and then further show that a
correct response would have provided a
valid basis for a challenge for cause
the motives for concealing information
may vary but only those reasons that
affect adjures impartiality can truly be
said to affect the fairness of a trial
so that is a two-prong standard and
regarding the first prong questions are
material if they have a natural tendency
to influence or are capable of
influencing the judge's determination
whether a juror can be impartial circuit
courts are split on whether the supreme
court's first prong requires some level
of intent behind the juror's
misstatement or omission the second
circuit where maxwell was tried requires
showing that the juror deliberately
withheld information jurors cannot be
faulted for failing to disclose certain
information when they were never asked
during the course of wadir to make those
kind of disclosures with respect to the
maxwell case david told reuters that he
flew through the jury questionnaire and
did not recall being asked whether he
had been a victim of sexual abuse david
told reporters he would have answered
honestly if asked explicitly about that
question now regarding the second prong
that requires the defendant to show that
if the juror had told the truth there
would have been a valid basis for a
challenge strike the second circuit
cases hold that the standard is
satisfied as long as a reasonable judge
made aware of the withheld information
would have excused the juror for cause
even if the disqualification was not
mandatory so in this case would judge
nathan have concluded under the totality
of the circumstances that the two jurors
lack the capacity and the will to decide
the case based on the evidence well this
is a high bar jury verdicts are usually
overturned only if there is an extreme
misconduct by that juror for example in
the us versus dowgerdas five defendants
were charged with seven billion dollars
in tax evasion juror number one
catherine conrad wrote a letter after
the verdict complementing the government
on all their work during the trial and
when the lawyers researched conrad they
discovered that she was not the
stay-at-home mother with a bachelor's
degree that she claimed to be in the
court forms conrad was actually a lawyer
who was suspended for chronic alcoholism
she had been convicted of several crimes
including punching a police officer
stealing a bag of shrimp and there was a
warrant out for her arrest in another
state she lied about being a plaintiff
in an ongoing personal injury case and
she described her husband as a reputed
mob boss conrad was later arrested after
she defied a subpoena to testify at the
hearing regarding a new trial she
admitted that she lied to make herself
more marketable as a juror and not
surprisingly the the judge vacated those
convictions now in the maxwell case the
pre-trial questionnaire asked jurors
whether they had ever been sexually
abused those who answered yes were later
questioned by judge nathan the presiding
judge about whether they could be
impartial and rule 33 of the federal
rules of criminal procedure authorizes a
district court to grant a motion for a
new trial if the interest of justice so
requires so would the omissions by these
jurors have disqualified them from the
jury well not necessarily it all depends
on how judge nathan assessed their
ability to fairly review the evidence
and it's anyone's guess what happens
next judge nathan has set a briefing
schedule for the motion for a new trial
uh they will weigh all of the evidence
and all of the statements and omissions
of these these jurors and it's anyone's
guess as to whether judge nathan will
grant a new trial here it's not like
maxwell is going free if she is
successful then the prosecutors will
have to redo the in trial again with a
new jury but it is not at all certain
that maxwell's conviction is going to
stand and while you have no control over
the trial or retrial of maxwell you do
have the ability to do good in this
world in fact you can do the most good
possible now i've long been a supporter
of effective altruism and today's
sponsor givewell makes that a reality
givewell spends over 20 000 hours each
year researching charitable
organizations and only recommends a few
of the highest impact evidence-backed
charities they've found over 50 000
donors have used givewell to donate more
than 750 million dollars and ensure that
their donations made the maximum impact
to save tens of thousands of lives and
improve the lives of millions more and
here's the best part givewell is
completely free givewell helps you
allocate your tax-deductible donations
to the charity you choose without taking
a cut they publish all their research
and recommendations on their site for
free no sign up required and when you
donate through givewell your donations
are still tax deductible in the u.s
givewell's top recommendation is to
donate to their maximum impact fund
which directs donations to the charity
or charities that give will has
determined to be the most effective each
quarter givewell is completely
transparent about how donations are
spent and how their decisions are made
they even have a web page devoted to
sharing the mistakes they've made along
the way givewell simplifies the process
of finding and giving to outstanding
charities because they do the
independent research they give me peace
of mind that their donations will do the
maximum good and they do the
evidence-based research that i would
want to do on my own and this part is
really incredible givewell is matching
donations from first-time donors dollar
for dollar up to 250 all you have to do
is click on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description to
donate and be sure to use the fundraiser
code legal eagle at checkout to make
sure your donation gets matched again
all you have to do to get 250 in
matching funds is click on the link and
use the code legaleagle and while you're
there click on this playlist with all my
other real law reviews for more analysis
of important legal issues or i'll see
you in court